you know what what i would use though
it's natural
capitalism uh it's a hundred percent
natural
rather than forced upon you collectivism
to me capitalism when they see when some
people apologize for it and we we all
say it because somebody else said it
which is what it's not perfect was the
best thing we got [ __ ] it's it's
natural it's it's you
we're naturally born capitalists
we are capitalists
it doesn't matter what you think about
we're capitalist everybody's a
capitalist even the socialist is a
capitalist you know even the communist
is a capitalist the communist is so
competitive that he wants you to believe
his argument is the best the only
difference between the capitalists and
the communists is the communist wants to
eliminate a competitor the capitalist
wants to have a competitor he just wants
to compete against the competitor to see
if he can make it or not one is trying
to eliminate the other one wants to
compete
allow me to see if i can do a better job
okay capitalism doesn't work when
bureaucrats and aristocrats show up
until then it's a great system